under surveillance since the start of
his journey
this is Sudesh Sherman the stratum
terrorist making his way to carry out an
attack a plain-clothed police officer
follows him on a blue motorbike this is
the first time we've seen a man being
tracked by specialist officers with this
CCTV we can now piece together the
attackers movements before he caused
terror on the streets of South London
this is where it all started
since Judah Sherman was released from
prison this is where he was living a
bail hostel in South London it's also
here where his mom brought him food just
days before the attack he left the
hostel just after 1:30 on Sunday
afternoon just yards away around the
corner on a quiet residential street
CCTV obtained by Sky News shows the
attacker heading to his target at 1:36
p.m. less than 3 minutes later the
undercover police officer is seen
following him on a motorbike Sudesh
Sherman then walked for just over half a
mile towards Streatham high road seen
here he passed a number of shops at 1:46
p.m. a bag covering his fake suicide
vest he was still being watched by
police he's now on the busy thoroughfare
where he carried out his bloody attack
he stole a knife from a small
convenience store within 60 seconds he
started stabbing people his first victim
was knifed in the back just outside the
local pub his second victim was seen
lying in a pool of blood outside a
supermarket just yards away 60 seconds
later by 158 p.m. Suresh a man was shot
dead by armed surveillance officers even
before the armed response unit arrived
Guiseppe was walking home from his
brother's house he was the first person
to help Monika Lautner one of the
attackers victims so whereabouts was she
stabbed
myself I need to help this girl I
looking around for this car by my name
is was just I need LT square let's say
because if it was my mom I'm bad guys if
it was a matter of seconds in Sudesh a
man stole a knife injured people and was
shot dead it only took him over 20
minutes to travel from where he was
staying to where he carried out his
terror attack this is something he's
wanted to do for a long time but his aim
of killing people was cut short by the
undercover officers following him just
moments behind in some am rashid sky
news